what constitutes a wise entrepreneur is
those who develop over time kind of
recognition and can extract data from
known any patterns they've seen but
patterns that other people have seen and
to me you know pattern recognition is
something that you just build into your
thinking process any time I'm now
looking at a deal or hearing about a new
startup i overlay visually I'm watching
a business model canvas as they're
describing it and they were filling in
boxes for me literally visually as
they're talking about their startup I'm
clicking off how many people have they
talked to and what have they learned and
I could do that just because it's a
pattern I've built up what I find
enjoyable is I could actually teach
those skills to others well you can't
teach to others what you hope for in
your lives and the careers of others are
what are called epiphanies and those are
these serendipitous snap patterns that
come together when you're not thinking
hard but when you're actually kind of in
a relaxed state walking on the beach
driving your car etc where all the data
you've been collecting for the last year
or two or you're a lifetime or month etc
snap together in a way that you weren't
even consciously processing it
those are company makers or career
makers or nobel prize makers and so I
considered two types of wisdom acquiring
pattern recognition skills and then
learning how to encourage your own
epiphanies
you